In many cases quicksort is one of
the most efficient sorting algorithms.
To do a quicksort you essentially
pick one of the values in
the array at random.
Move all values larger than it above it
and all values below it, lower than it.
The value that you pick
initially is called a pivot.
You continue on recursively, picking a
pivot in the upper and lower sections of
the array, sorting them similarly
until the whole array is sorted.
Okay, let's watch this in action.
First we need to select a pivot.
The convention is to pick
the last element as your pivot.
So let's go ahead and do that.
Our first element is
larger than our pivot.
So we need to move it behind the pivot.
However, we're doing an in-place sort.
So we need to move the element in
front of the pivot to make room.
So in this step we're
moving 8 to the last block,
2 to the second to last block, and
10 all the way up to the first block.
This seems a little counterintuitive.
You would think that we would
move 10 back and not forward.
Just hold on for now,
we'll see exactly why this works soon.
So we did our shift and
now we can make another comparison.
Now we get to take a look at 10.
Since 10 is bigger than 2 we need to,
again, move 10 back.
Move 2 up and move whatever's
in front of 2 up as well.
Great, one more swap down.
Finally, we have 0 at
the front of our array,
which is actually smaller
than our pivot of 2.
That's pretty great, but now we
just move to the second element and
do the same process with that one.
Since 3 is greater than 2 we'll need
to shift around everything again.
Awesome, this is looking so much better.
Since 7 is still bigger than 2, we
need to do another comparison, though.
Here's the swap we need to make.
And this is what our
array looks like now.
This is definitely good.
2 is in the right place.
We've checked all the elements before
it and we're sure they're less than it.
And we've put all of these elements
after it that are all definitely
bigger than it.
Because we're sure everything
in the array below 2
is actually less than 2 and
everything above 2 is greater than 2,
we know that 2 is in
the exact right place.
I'm going to color code it so we know
that we don't need to move it again.
At this point we normally
do the same process for
everything smaller than the pivot and
everything bigger than the pivot.
Let's start with the smaller part first.
We select our pivot and
compare to everything before.
Since 0 is actually less than 1,
there's nothing we need to do.
And with just one comparison,
we know that both of these are in
the right place and we can move on.
Now in the second half of the array,
we select a pivot.
Since 7 and 3 are both smaller than
the pivot, we won't need to move them.
However, 8 is bigger than the pivot.
So we'll need to do a swap here.
Now that our swap's complete
we can see that 8 and
10 are actually in their
eventual positions.
Everything less than 8 was already below
8 so we didn't need to move it at all.
Okay, now we only have two elements
left that maybe need to be sorted.
Again, all we have to do here is
assign 3 as a pivot and compare.
We'll see that these two
need to be switched.
Do that quickly and
then our whole array is done.